[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans audition
publique exceptionnellement enregistré
ce soir nous sommes trois semaines après
l'élection présidentielle enfin un
premier ministre plus tôt une première
ministre demain ou mercredi le
gouvernement ça lancera définitivement
les législatives même si les candidats
sont déjà sur le terrain comme notre
invité ce soir dans son rôle ya pradier
merci beaucoup êtes candidat à votre
réélection dans le lot vous avez lancé
votre campagne vous avez même inauguré
un qg avec une 4l joué trois lettres
quelques couleurs elle est blanche elle
est blanche non répond-il au parti mais
elle est blanche rappelle que vous êtes
aussi secrétaire général de dell est
reparti coût est évidemment par le score
humiliant valérie pécresse au 1er tour
vous nous direz si vous avez dit digérer
cette défaite quelles leçons vous en
tirer quels programmes alternatifs
proposés vous quelles sont vos ambitions
évidemment pour le groupe à l'assemblée
à l'issue des législatives
en somme l air combien de divisions pour
cette législature dans ce paysage
politique recomposée toutes ces
questions brigitte boucher est en train
de me voulait poseront la bataille de la
présidentielle
elle vous intéresse ça va être chaud
semble-t-il c'est se fit ravinel qui
vous interrogera et puis dans un quart
d'heure la question d'actu de vincent
vos du figaro live mais d'abord nous
sommes un jour particulier jean castex a
démissionné tout à l'heure jean castex
qui était issu de vos rangs quel bilan
vous tirez est-ce que vous lui tirer son
chapeau finalement puisque c'est un
homme qui part plus tôt sous les
honneurs je suis sûrement le plus mal
placé pour dresser des lauriers à jean
castex j'ai du respect pour jean castex
comme j'ai du respect pour tous ceux qui
ont qui ont servi notre pays il a été
pour moi le serviteurs dociles
d'emmanuel macro et j'ai une opposition
claire à la politique d' emmanuel macron
donc au delà de l'homme que je n'ai pas
à juger d'ailleurs je considère que
c'est une règle qu'on doit si c'est en
politique je considère que le bilan de
jean castex c'est précisément le bilan
des manuels macron et c'est un bilan que
j'ai combattu vous ne me reconnaissez
aucun mérite si je lui rose connaît une
docilité peut-être même une plasticité
alors il se trouve que je considère pas
que ce soit une qualité en politique
mais ça l'est peut-être quand on est
emmanuel macron et qu'on choisit un un
premier ministre il a été un serviteur
docile et c'est vrai que tout le monde
n'est pas capable de le faire moi j'en
serais bien incapable la docilité dans
votre bouche ça n'est pas précisément un
compliment vraiment mais c'est utile
aussi pour servir l'état et en
l'occurrence problement qu'il n'a fait
vous a pas toujours bien traité à
l'assemblée en tout cas il a été un
adversaire dans les questions au
gouvernement sont souviens assez coriace
plus coriaces peut-être que y attendiez
oui peut-être au fur et à mesure du
temps il a pris un peu de férocité non
le vrai point de divergence que j'ai
toujours eue avec jean castex c'est que
je n'ai toujours pas compris quel était
son âme politique ce qui m'intrigue nam
son âme paul arthur
ses convictions profondes on l'a
d'appliquer strictement ce que le
président de la république lui demander
de faire est ce qu'être premier ministre
c'est être haut fonctionnaire je ne
crois pas je pense qu'on imprime aussi
marc politique
j'ai pas le sentiment que jean castex le
fassent alors peut-être que dans cette
période ça qu'on venait d'avoir un haut
fonctionnaire au fond qui exerce un rôle
de super préfet comme premier ministre
c'est oublier un peu vite que dans la
vème république le premier ministre sait
pas qu'un super préfet c'est aussi une
personnalité politique ça n'enlève rien
sûrement à ses qualités humaines je ne
connais pas assez pour le avoir à le
juger je dis juste qu'on s'est peut être
habitué à ce que le premier ministre
notamment avec jean castex n'est pas une
empreinte politique particulière ça en
arranger quelques-uns je suis pas sûr
que ça fasse du bien la démocratie vous
donner à tout et lorsque vous pensez du
nouveau chef de la nouvelle chef du
gouvernement il faudrait d'abord avant
cela si vous voulez bien revenir sur
quelques questions importantes qui sont
des questions européennes obligent à
mais qu'on est sur un fond de guerre en
en ukraine et il ya eu un événement
historique hier c'est que la finlande a
officiellement demandé son adhésion à
l'otan l'alliance atlantique or
précisément la russie a justifié
l'invasion d'ukraine par le seul fait
qu'elles se sentaient menacés par cette
autant est-ce qu'il faut que l'otan
accueille en effet elle a dit qu'elle le
ferait mais ce que vous êtes favorable à
ce que finlande arrive au plus vite dans
les rangs de l'otan oui j'y suis
favorable personnel et par conséquent
mais le sujet n'est plus de savoir ce
qui peut fâcher ou pas vladimir poutine
jusque là on a avancé tactiquement en se
demandant ce qu'ils allaient pouvoir le
fâche et parfois même en je pense qu'on
a cherché des excuses à ceux qui est
inexcusable aujourd'hui donc peu importe
les décisions qui seront prises si elles
conviennent ou pas de la dmr poutine
aujourd'hui vladmir poutine est pour moi
sortie du jeu international
définitivement donc nous n'avons plus de
discussion à avoir c'est un point pour
moi absolument ferme et catégorique et
donc l'adhésion à l'otan pour moi est la
meilleure manière de protéger les
territoires autour de l'ukraine et je
pense que c'est la priorité aujourd'hui
on rappelle que la finlande à 1300 km de
frontière avec la russie ce qui la rend
particulièrement évidemment vulnérables
à d'éventuelles représailles comme l'a
dit vladimir poutine et que la suède
aussi emboîté le pas à la demande il ne
faut pas humilier la russie a dit
emmanuel macron il ya une semaine à
strasbourg dans un discours sur l'europe
il évoquait des futures négociations de
paix est-ce qu'il a raison il a raison
il ne faut pas humide et la russie et le
peuple russes il a raison de le dire
parce que zelensky je ne sais pas si la
région ne m'a plaquée sur un sénégal n'a
pas apprécié et mentaux qu'est ce qui se
cache derrière ce mot est ce que dit la
vraie réflexion c'est de ne pas humilier
la russie est évidemment personne n'a
eue milliards russie mais est ce qu'il
se cache derrière cela la volonté de
rediscuter avec vladimir poutine
lui-même ça c'est une autre affaire et
moi je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent aujourd'hui que vladimir
poutine est disqualifié de la diplomatie
internationale on peut pas en permanence
tout excuser de la dmr poutine il y aura
demain des crimes de guerre a jugé et si
ces crimes de guerre s'avère comme
manifestement c'est le cas être vrai
vladimir poutine ne sera plus un
interlocuteur politique et je ne suis
donc pas certain que dans la déclaration
du président de la république qu'il y
ait un acte de courage j'ai plutôt le
sentiment que c'est une manière de
commencer à amorcer des discussions avec
poutine des concessions oui c'est ce que
craint tout de suite évidemment le cren
des concessions territoriales d'ailleurs
reproché manuel mâcon elle est déjà sur
ce terrain ce qui me fera beaucoup c'est
que depuis désormais quasiment deux mois
nous ne savons rien des discussions qui
sont menées entre différents pays et
vladimir poutine il comparaît son client
dans le cadre des négociations d un tous
les cas des discussions puisque le chef
de l'état français dit lui-même qu'il
continue à avoir des contacts et des
discussions et nous n'avons pas le
moindre écho tout cela alors je
comprends que la diplomatie n'est pas
une affaire qui s'est avérée un peu
comme un ton qui s'est déguisée qui nous
aiguille est que par exemple emmanuel
macron plaide pour des couvoirs
humanitaires qu'ils doivent comme nous
sommes demandés cessez-le-feu voit la
gestion de l'urgence je suis d'accord il
ya une transparence la question c'est
est ce qu'il y à des négociations qui
sont engagés y compris sur les français
qui en abritent auriol et quand je ne
sais pas tout ce que je sais c'est que
les différents indicateurs qui qui qui a
qui sont annoncés les différentes
déclarations me pousse plutôt à penser
cela j'entends que la diplomatie est une
affaire qui ne s'étale pas dans
l'immédiat évidemment mais je dis aussi
que viendra un moment où la décision que
la france prendra au nom de l'europe
pour ce qui est des manuels macron de
discussion ou pas avec la russie aura
des conséquences de très long terme sur
la gestion de la diplomatie du monde
c'est cela dont il s'agit donc là nous
sommes en train de gérer cela
aurélien pradié une question qui
évidemment j'imagine vous interpelle
aussi c'est la déclaration d' emmanuel
macron qui propose non pas que le
craindre rejoigne l'union européenne
tout de suite pas le 28e pays à la place
d'autres inquiets demandent entrée dans
l'union européenne en tout cas l ukraine
pas tout de suite en revanche oui pour
une communauté politique qui serait à
côté de l'union européenne qui
permettrait à ces pays de partager un
certain nombre de valeurs et même
d'éléments pratique le marché par
exemple commun si je puis dire mais la
liberté de circulation des biens mais
pas d'être vraiment au coeur du réacteur
en pennsylvanie des caisses que l'union
européenne est ce que l'union européenne
est un outil qui sert seulement à
protéger contre les interventions
militaires à protéger contre des
interventions économiques ou est-ce que
c'est plus que ça moi je pense que
l'union européenne c'est beaucoup plus
que ça si l'on veut que l'union
européenne soit forte il faut qu'elle
ait une culture commune qu'elle est une
histoire commune je ne suis pas certain
que nous l'ayons avec l'ukraine en
revanche tout cela dit quoi tout cela
dit que nous n'avons pas d'outils
aujourd'hui de protection internationale
compris l'otan avec ne fonctionne pas
est-ce que ce que l'idée de cette
communauté politique donc à côté d'une
européenne c'est une bonne façon de dire
à l'ukraine oui peut-être plus tard en
attendant déjà partageant des valeurs je
vous êtes une démocratie comme nous il
faut juste que vous régliez certaines
problèmes qui ne sont pas des détails
d'ailleurs non mais qu'est ce qu'une
communauté politique qu'est ce qu'une
communauté européenne à côté de l'union
européenne ça que je ne comprends pas
aujourd'hui moi je suis prêt à avoir
cette discussion pour peu qu'on
n'utilise pas l'union européenne à
toutes les sauces pour le dire
simplement si il est utile d'avoir une
périphérie qui permet de protéger qui
permet d'embarquer dans une aventure
politique commune pourquoi pas encore
faut-il le définir une communauté
politique ce sont des mots et des maux
assez vain à ce stade c'est une journée
politique pas comme les autres va
continuer d'en parler avec brigitte
busch est à mme tran huy mais d'abord
nous allons rejoindre évidemment vincent
roux
bonjour vincent
bonsoir elizabeth bonsoir à aurélien
pradié white en train de boire et un
vers leurs excuses et vous répond voilà
bonsoir mais il faut que je lui pose une
question peut-être avoir alors on veut
faire un petit à petit pas de côté mais
c'est dans l'actualité de cette journée
en plus exactement de cette soirée le
conseil municipal de grenoble va
peut-être voter en tous les cas il va en
débattre
de l'autorisation du burkini dans les
piscines si le vote est favorable préfet
de l'isère a déjà prévenu qu'il
saisirait le tribunal administratif et
auparavant laurent wauquiez président l
air de la région rhône alpes et auvergne
a dit qu'il couperait les subventions à
la mairie de grenoble est ce que vous
êtes sur leur longueur d'onde oui
totalement et je vais l'expliquer je
considère que ceux dont la république
souffre sûrement le plus depuis de
nombreuses années c'est d'avoir des
attaques que jusque là on a minima
banalisée qui porte un message beaucoup
plus grave que ce que certains veulent
bien dire le burqini c'est pas seulement
un vêtement c'est un geste politique
d'ailleurs on voit bien la manière dont
le débat est portée il n'est pas porté
que sur la question vestimentaire
moi je suis un républicain je sais à
quel point l'espace de la république est
un espace qu'on doit protéger de tous
les signes religieux notamment et le
protéger absolument
définitivement et fermement donc il ya
pas pour moi l'ombre d'un doute et je
vais même vous dire je pense que ceux
qui parmi la classe politique défendent
excuses ce genre de deux percées ne sont
pas totalement républicain
les promoteurs de cette mesure disent
que d'un autre côté ils sont là pour
l'autorisation
d'arrivée librement enfin de choisir
librement sa tenue à la piscine le
burqini pour les unes le topless pour
les autres moi il m'a fait écouter tout
ça ça commence à bien faire s'il ya une
seule de un seul de ces militants qui
croit vraiment que le burqini n'est que
n'est qu'une mode vestimentaire c'est
que où il est totalement ignorants ou il
nous prend pour des imbéciles et je le
redis ce qui se joue derrière ce n'est
pas un détail ce qui se joue derrière
c'est sûrement un affrontement entre
ceux qui se croient profondément à la
république à l'exigence de la république
et ceux qui n'y croient pas ou qui n'y
croient plus coupet subventions comme le
propose laurent wauquiez qui menacent de
le faire programmable à elle et le
président du conseil régional
de la région verne rhône alpes à quoi ça
sert dans le fond il va priver de
piscine tous ceux qui portent un burkini
mais aussi tous ceux qui ne portent un
maillot demain franchement est-ce que
c'est toute la difficulté du moment
alors embouti a totalement raison
d'utiliser les moyens qui sont qui sont
les siens mais au fond on ne devraient
pas avoir ce débat c'est la loi de la
république qui devrait fixer les règles
définies mais ce que la mesure de
rétorsion proprement enfin est approprié
je ne sais pas tout ce que je sais c'est
que le combat que mène laurent wauquiez
avec les moyennes président région qui
sont les siens est un bon combat et
qu'il doit continuer à le mener je dis
juste ensemble va moyen peut-être ni ses
tables sait il le fait avec les moyens
qui sont les siens c'est à la loi de la
république de mener ce combat là
et il a tout à fait raison aaron
seulement les trains saisi exactement
d'aller jusqu'au bout j'espère que la
justice administrative donnera raison et
si ce n'est pas le cas il faut que la
loi de la république clarifie
définitivement ce débat là merci vincent
on vous retrouve bien sûr la semaine
prochaine en direct du figaro live en
face de vos brigitte busch est entre
nous et mesdames d'abbas est vrai que
j'étais un pic au mans ce soir sa une
avec des questions tiens qui intéresse
votre groupe on y voit soir aurélien
pradié je voulais vous parler de damien
abad qui est le président du groupe
l'est républicain ici à l'assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui la p2 et il n'aura
pas de candidat renaissance face à lui
aux élections législatives est ce que
pour vous du coup c'est un traître tu es
moi je gère déjà ma propre conscience
qui ce qui est pas mal donc je vais pas
gérer la conscience des autres moi je
serais très heureux le soir du 1er et du
2ème tour des élections législatives
d'avoir gagné dans ma circonscription
soumet couleur sans que personne ne
m'est fait un petit
monte escalier pour que ce soit plus
facile ça monte escalier là pour damien
mecs vous pensez qu'il allait négocier
quelque chose il ya quelque chose
derrière il ya un deal derrière pour
vous peut-être qu'on peut essayer pour
pompes dont concitoyens et nos
téléspectateurs se porte mieux de ce
d'arrêter de se prendre les sous les
hautes pour des imbéciles oui évidemment
que quand dans votre circonscription
vous n'avez pas de candidat la
république en marche que le
secrétaire-général de la république en
marche dit qu il le fait par
bienveillance à votre égard c'est que
vous avez 10 le faire en responsabilité
parce que damien abad aurait appelé à
voter pour emmanuel macron au deuxième
tour face à marine le pen tout ça c'est
du baratin fois excusez moi mais je
pense que la classe politique gagnerait
à assumer les choix que chacun fait
aussi damien abad veut demain pour
rejoindre la majorité qu'il assume de le
faire et j'aurai un désaccord profond
avec lui et je le lui dirai ce qui pour
moi est devenu insupportable dans
l'attitude politique c'est le fait de ne
même pas assumer les choix que l'on fait
soi même si tu voulais demander de les
clarifier que je ne suis avant le 20 mai
qui est la date limite de dépôt
d'excideuil tournée de clarifier je lui
demande à lui comme aux autres de cesser
de prendre ses amis ses collègues et les
français pour des imbéciles
ça ferait du bien la démocratie vous
voulez demander de démissionner du poste
demande aux résidents on met du coup ça
se traduit comment
s'est déroulé l'exclure était à nous
prendre pour des imbéciles donc je dis
là je le lui dis oui mais donc je vous
le dis sinon
je lui de rejoindre la majorité tu le
fais maintenant tu en assumera les
conséquences et puis si tu le fais c'est
que tu leur as choisi donc grand garçon
mais arrêtons d'avoir le cul entre deux
chaises pardonnez moi d'avoir une
expression un peu brutal parce que c'est
insupportable pour la démocratie c'est
insupportable pour les camarades pour
les compagnons politiques mais c'était
un supporter s'il ne le fait pas vous
n'allez pas l'exclure par avance des
républicains à ces traces je ne sais pas
ce qu'il fera de toute façon lorsque
vous prenez les électeurs et les
français pour des imbéciles vous le
payez tôt ou tard si c'est pas là c'est
après ça se paye un jour vous avez un
candidat de substitution éventuellement
si toutefois et rejoignez les rangs de
la majorité tout est prêt dans tous les
cas pour faire en sorte que si les uns
les autres rejoignez les rangs de la
majorité ce qui est leur choix le plus
strict alors nous ayons notre position
claire qu'il envoyait un candidat sous
nos couleurs voilà vous êtes très clair
avec damien d'avant à banes que vous le
serez aussi avec erik satie tout ce
raffut effectivement au tour de damien
abad eric ciotti lui n'a pas de candidat
reconquête face à lui ce qu'il doit lui
clarifier sa situation vis-à-vis sa de
l'extrême droite ans je n'ai jamais été
borgne dans mes analyses politiques ce
qui vaudra un côté vos de l'autre moi je
serais très malheureux très très mal à
l'aise d'avoir été élu avec l'aide de la
république a marre je serai tout aussi
malheureux et mal à l'aise d'avoir être
d'avoir été élu avec l'aide de dérision
et de marine le pen exactement
écoutez moi je les traite réclament ou
les ita si je l'écoutais nuit en bourse
de celle ci je les écoute tenu
constamment ce discours là depuis
l'origine et je pense qu'on ne gagne
jamais à ne pas être clair ni d'un côté
ni de l'autre moi je serai eric ciotti
je prierai tous les soirs pour avoir un
candidat d'eric zemmour face à man avait
ce qu'on pensait que c'est un hasard je
ne sais pas si c'est un hasard qu'on
peut la même façon que vous pensez que
damien abad l'a fait parce que il a
négocié quelque chose il en avait dans
quelque chose érection t attends quoi
j'en sais rien voulu poser la question
je sais juste que dans ces situations là
on est sanctionné par les électeurs tôt
ou tard et ça je me suis absolument par
l air est ce qu'on est sanctionné wi lan
faudra il faudra il le faudra aux
élections mais aussi tous ceux qui
auront la tentation de vouloir jouer une
aventure d'arrière boutique de deal
politique en perdant leur âme politiques
devront être sanctionnées si je suis pas
là en train de faire l'inquisiteur jeu
juste en train de dire que la politique
c'est d'abord une affaire de clarté pas
pour son parti politique mais pour
respecter les français ça ferait du bien
de lire et ce alors qu'ils engraissent
la question juste avant que vous avez
posé tome est ce qu il a lui aussi
pardon qu entre le fais dans cette
situation là oui d'accord mais lorsqu'on
interroge il nous dit clairement je lui
posais la question eric ciotti qu'en
l'occurrence eux ils ne l'avaient pas
souhaité espérons qu'il al'art le
momentum candidats il y en a qui ont
clarifié leur situation constance le
grip robin reda marine brenier jean
carles grelier avant il ya eu eric
woerth eux ils ont franchi le rubicon
ils sont allés du côté de renaissance
ils ont donc choisi leur chef est-ce
qu'ils vont vous manqué non mais je
pense que non non non crée pas non plus
pour sa d'eric woerth il ne manquera pas
je ne lui manquerai pas non plus non en
fait je sais qu'il ya toujours des
considérations locales etc mais mais la
politique c'est quoi est ce que la
politique c'est de sauver son poste à
tout prix quelle que soit la combinaison
ou est-ce que c'est d'abord un peu de
panache c'est ça que vous vous dites de
riz c'est ce que je me disais parce
qu'il ya des configurations locales
c'est des petits arrangements et des
gens mais ulysse lui ce qu'ils se
trouvent moi je trouve ça triste oui je
trouve ça triste moi je trouve que la
politique c'est beau pardon je paraître
on peut y lire en disant ça je trouve
que c'est beau suis engagé à 16 ans je
trouve que c'est beau la politique et ça
se fait de la plus belle manière on
n'est pas parfait on n'est pas des héros
mais la droiture politique la vertu dans
le comportement politique ce n'est pas
un détail et donc beaucoup des députés
que vous citez ont passé cinq ans à
critiquer emmanuel macron comment est ce
que en l'espace de quelques nuits on en
devient un fan absolu tout ça c'était
insupportable un retournement de veste
pour vous oui mais c'est assez banal
quand j'étais assez quel geste politique
et non c'est pas classique c'est pas
classique c'est triste c'est même un peu
misérable et je pense qu'il faut mettre
des mots sur les choses quelqu'un qui
trahit sa famille politique pour une
gamelle c'est un traître politique point
à la ligne et arrêtons faudrait par
exemple sa conviction et donnez moi mais
oui eric woerth a passé cinq ans a
expliqué à quel point manuelle macro
était de mauvais président de la
république il n'y a pas d'évolution si
ce n'est de l'opportunisme politique et
je pense qu'on se soignerait un peu
notre démocratie à mettre des mots sur
les comportements même quand se sentent
pas de beaux comporte n'y a peut-être
pas que de l'opportunisme politique
c'était une ligne qui pouvait être aussi
prôné par l'ancien président de la
république nicolas sarkozy une figure
tutélaire de votre parti
finalement ils sont pas si nombreuses
que ça c'est du coup un échec personnel
de nicolas sarkozy moi j'ai dit ce que
j'avais à dire s'unir et à sarkozy je le
lis beaucoup respecté je le respecte
toujours l'avait pas envoyé dire
ailleurs non mais parce que je pense
qu'ils temps en temps c'est bien de dire
les choses j'ai dit qu'il fallait rompre
avec le sarkozysme et faut tourner une
page beaucoup de monde le pense personne
n'osait vraiment le dire je n'ai pas eu
le sentiment d'être d'avoir passé le
bûcher en le disant et peut-être même
que j' y compris rendu service à nicolas
sarkozy en lui permettant de se libérer
d'une famille politique qui
manifestement n'est plus tout à fait la
sienne je dis toujours j'ai appris
nicolas sarkozy que le courage en
politique c'était la rupture voilà il
faut rompre avec le passé y compris avec
les page du sarkozysme et la nuit face
et nicolas sarkozy non mais c'est notre
histoire politique mais l'histoire
politique ça fait pas tout l'avenir
politique comment voulez vous demain que
nous reconstruisions la droite si en
permanence on doit aller quémander aux
uns et aux autres de nos anciens tel ou
tel soutien tel ou tel bénédiction c'est
pas comme ça que l' aventure politique
se fait nicolas sarkozy lui-même
lorsqu'il le part à la conquête du
pouvoir
le fait en rupture avec jacques chirac
c'est comme ça qu'il va devant les
français et donc c'est un moment où
sûrement qu'il faut tourner ses pages un
désaccord désormais politique avec
nicolas sarkozy ça ne m'empêchera pas de
continuer à avoir du respect pour lui
mais je dirais je continuerai à dire
qu'il faut tourner la page du sarkozysme
alors en tout cas tous ces départs de
députés et le score réalisé par votre
candidate à la présidentielle réduisent
vos chances d'avoir un groupe important
à l'assemblée nationale est un peu plus
de sens aujourd'hui
vous êtes inquiets sur les législatives
pas tant que ça alors je suis tête
froide le plus possible d'abord parce
que je suis en campagne électorale tous
les jours donc on a parfois un peu de
mal à être lucide mais qu'est-ce qui
fait l'élection d'un député ce qui fait
l'élection d'un député qu'on sous-estimé
beaucoup c'est la reconnaissance locale
a parfois ont balayé d'un revers de main
en disant on ne sait pas très important
si le lien humain qu'on peut avoir avec
ses concitoyens c'est quand même un
élément essentiel de la politique
politique ce n'est pas qu'une affaire
d'étiquettes et je sais que les députés
les républicains sont parmi ceux qui
sont le plus ancré dans les territoires
qui ont le plus de liens avec leurs
concitoyens et ça ça peut créer
fondamental de coller socialiste l'était
également et après la défaite de
françois hollande il se retrouvait avec
un groupe d'une trentaine de députés
est-ce que vous pensez que vous pourrez
avoir plus de 30 députés alors mais
nationale je le pense je pense même
qu'on peut surprendre je pense que jean
luc mélenchon et ses candidats
téléguidé qui sont de véritables
marionnettes n'auront pas les scores
kills qui sont annoncés en c est le
premier groupe d'opposition je ne sais
pas je n'ai pas de pronostic
il vous espérez combien de députés je
n'en sais rien je n'ai jamais joué au
loto et c'est pas aujourd'hui je vous le
savez pas ce que nous tous car régie en
réalité je n'en sais rien mais je pense
que nous pouvons surprendre et que nous
serons comme nous l'avons été durant
cinq ans à l'assemblée nationale une
opposition solide peut-être même quand
vous souvent enrayé après le score et
bien justement parce qu'on s'attend à ce
que nous disparaissions et nous ne
disparaîtront pas parce que l'ancrage
des députés les républicains et d'une
véritable est une véritable puissance
électorale et vous le verrez j'en suis
certain lors des élections législatives
alors on aimerait bien connaître votre
stratégie en cas de 2e tour cia
renaissance contre le rassemblement
national est ce que c'est la même
stratégie qu'à la présidentielle c'est à
dire aucune voix pour le fn et est ce
que c'est la même stratégie s'il ya
renaissance face à elle elle fit aucune
voie pour aller fille bon pendant les
mois mais je ne suis pas sûr d'avoir
tous les scénarios en est et je vais
vous dire quelque chose qui va vous
décevoir mais pour moi l'objectif c'est
que les députés candidats les
républicains soit le plus haut possible
au premier tour botté en touche et la
question oui mais parce que je vais y
aura forcément des duels où vous ne
serez pas on dirait pas là et vous
m'interrogerais à ce moment là je vous
répondrais ce que je peux simplement
vous dire c'est que jamais je n'ai fait
la moindre courte échelle à l'extrême
droite que je considère que marine le
pen comme eric zemmour sont les tenants
d'une extrême droite et que jamais dans
mon parcours politique vous me
demanderez être faible à leur égard
jamais
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la posture
de jean luc mélenchon aujourd'hui qui se
voit premier ministre qui espère avoir
du poids à l'assemblée nationale être le
premier groupe d'opposition président
est peut-être la commission des finances
est-ce que l'attitude de jean luc
mélenchon depuis quelques années et
singulièrement depuis quelques jours est
une attitude républicaine
pardon devoir poser le débat je vais
vous dire pourquoi je me pose cette
question j'ai pas la réponse d'abord je
le vois piétiné le fonctionnement de nos
institutions
le fait de s'autoproclamer
potentiellement premier ministre pardon
de vous dire que nepal aurait la règle
de fonctionnement nos institutions et
quand on est un républicain aussi
cultivé que jean luc mélenchon ne peut
pas ignorer qu'il fait une entorse au
fonctionnement républicain de notre
démocratie
a non je pense que c'est un bon coup
médiatique mais je pense que c'est un
mauvais coup politique parce que ce que
j'entends y compris chez moi depuis
quelques jours c'est le fait que jean
luc mélenchon inquiète il ne rassure pas
il inquiète il inquiète parce qu'on le
voit je le redis pousser les barrières
de tout ce qui faisait les garde-fous de
notre république de notre organisation
progressivement peut-être même que nos
concitoyens se rendent compte que depuis
cinq ans à l'assemblée nationale la
première vocation des députés insoumis a
été 2 pardon mais de bordés lisez
l'assemblée nationale et qu'une
démocratie n'est pas fait pour être
bloqué une démocratie elle est faite
pour fonctionner je ne suis pas certain
qu'avec jean luc mélenchon majoritaire
notre démocratie en attendant elle est
parvenue à rassembler autour de lui le
nombreuses forces de gauche y compris le
parti socialiste europe écologie les
verts le parti communiste il arrive à
organiser la gauche oui simplement en
train de vandaliser l'assemblée
nationale non mais moi cette partie là
ne m'intéresse pas ce que je crois c'est
qu'il a pas rassembler le monde ce que
je crois c'est qu'il a tué le parti
socialiste ça c'est la sphère du parti
socialiste mais elle ne répond pas une
demande de radicalité forte c'est une
vraie question le savez c'est une vraie
question est est ce que le politique
doit y céder c'est ça la vraie question
est ce que le rôle du politique c'est
d'être demain des agitateurs est-ce que
c'est cela moi vous m'avez souvent
entendue dans mes propos être radical
dans les réformes à mener dans les
projets à porter parfois dans les mots
que je prononce mais pour autant vous ne
m'avez jamais entendu dépassé les
limites de ce que font les connaissant
les règles république aux aspirations
des électeurs 10 ans est touché par le
décor présidentielle à la gauche
daniel macro et donc il reste plus de
radicalité là une question fondamentale
que vous posez est ce que le rôle du
politique et d'attiser les haines je ne
le crois ni pour eric zemmour ni pour
jean luc mélenchon et je pense que c'est
pas le rôle de la police est tellement
facile d'être la caisse de résonance de
toutes les haines c'est tellement simple
la vraie difficulté mais aussi la vraie
beauté la vraie noblesse de la politique
c'est d'être capable de récolter cn de
les entendre et d'y apporter des
solutions c'est tout l'un verse ce que
fait jean luc mélenchon marine le pen ou
eric zemmour justement à parler un peu
de solutions en tout cas des de ce que
veut faire emmanuel macron en ce début
de quinquennat et annoncé un projet de
loi de finances rectificative pour le
mois de juillet un premier texte avec de
nombreuses mesures de soutien au pouvoir
d'achat chaque alimentation déjà du
point d'indicé des fonctionnaires et
indexation des retraites etc etc est-ce
que ça va dans le bon sens est-ce que
vous allez vous voter ces mesures je les
verrai nous aurons là comme première
urgence à gérer le pouvoir d'achat
immédiat c'est une certitude à l'arche
collective il propose des mesures
concrètes dans le faudra et génère nous
en débattrons mais c'est certain qu'on
ne peut pas laisser les français dans la
situation désastreuse dans laquelle ils
sont aujourd'hui il n'empêchera qu'il
nous faudra ensuite traiter tous les
problèmes de fond que nous n'avons pas
traité la question de la réforme des
retraites la question des salaires qui
pour moi est un sujet absolument semble
se poser toujours l'augmentation des
salaires telle qu'elle était prévue dans
le programme de valérie pécresse moi ce
que je propose c'est que nous reposions
la question de quel sens on les salaires
aujourd'hui quel sens ça le salaire
d'une aide à domicile qui fait un
travail extrêmement difficile et qui est
payé un salaire de misère quel est le
sens d'un trader qui va gagner des
centaines de milliers d'euros en
l'espace de quelques semaines ça se
traduit comment la part la question de
la participation
moi je souhaite que nous ayons une
grande conférence qui soit pas là pour
blablater mais qui repose la question de
la structuration des salaires mt gros
oui on peut tout à fait le faire pour
des fonctionnaires on peut tout à fait
le faire pour ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
des métiers de service on peut tout à
fait le faire en considérant que la
participation elle n'est pas calée sur
le bénéfice de l'entreprise puisqu'il
n'ya pas mais sur l'utilité sociale cds
réflexion que les échos c'est l'état qui
est intéressant c'est l'état qui paye
l'intéressement où il va mieux là
salaires parce qu'un salaire mais la
meute et l'intéressement ont fait partie
du salaire si de même on retravaille
effet l'impression c'est une vieille
vieille mesure ils se défendent l
général de gaulle non mais si on que sur
cela n'avance pas beaucoup l'a dit et
puis surtout notre économie a
fondamentalement changé toute
libéralisation de la société pour moi un
sujet absolument colossal est ce que
l'idée que nous nous faisons du travail
aujourd'hui sont des jeunes gens qui à
deux heures du matin ils vont des sushis
sur un vélo sans aucune protection
sociale et avec un salaire de misère
c'est pas l'idée que je me fais un
certain d'accord avec la france
insoumise 1 pour le coup qui a porté ces
mesures là au niveau européen peut-être
que la seule radicalité commune que j'ai
avec la france insoumis c'est de vouloir
changer les choses sur l'urbanisation en
tout cas vouloir changer la vie de mes
concitoyens sauf que nous ne faisons pas
de la délation comprends bien vous
voterez toutes les mesures d'urgence et
vous demandez une réflexion beaucoup
plus approfondie sur le sens des
salaires et donc la juste rémunération
bien sûr et français à leur poste
alimentation vous voterez l'indexation
des retraites la solution de notre
assemblée en bas on verrait le détail du
taqsim et autres des mesures sûrement
supplémentaires et complémentaires c'est
quelque chose qui me conviendront pas
mais tout ce qui permettra de répondre à
l'urgence de pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens
il faudra évidemment le soutien juste la
suppression de la redevance c'est une
mesure pouvoir d'achat pour vous est ce
que c'est bon oui c'est une bonne
musique candidats proposés par notre
candidate elle a été proposée par
plusieurs députés les républicains
depuis plusieurs années là aussi vous
voyez sur ce sujet comme sur la d
conjugale isation de l'allocation adulte
handicapé si le président de la
république
et l'ensemble de ses députés avaient
écouté un peu plus ses députés les
républicains on aurait gagné beaucoup de
temps sur des sujets fondamentaux mais
il va ce sont des positions qu'il est en
train d'adopter parce que justement
pousser c'est pour ça que les députés
les républicains sont ceux qui ont été
les plus utiles bergie ses mots sur la
question des retraites emmanuel macron
est maintenant favorable à la retraite à
65 ans en 2030 64 ans en 2028 gérard
larcher le président du sénat a souligné
que c'est très proche de la réforme
paramétrique que prenait que prône l air
là encore vous y êtes donc favorable eh
bien écoutez quitte à détourner un peu
dans ma famille politique je considère
que la question de l'âge n'est pas une
question essentielle et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi effectivement vous
admire de sel dans votre parti le sais
pas si je suis seul mais sont mes
convictions
moi je vais peut-être partir à soixante
dix ans à la retraite je serai pas
physiquement cas c'est peut-être que
nous ne le serons pas les uns les autres
en revanche quelqu'un qui aura travaillé
jusqu'à 55 ans sur des chantiers en
extérieur dans des horaires de nuit sera
cassée donc la question de l'âge de
départ pour moi n'est pas la question
fondamentale la question fondamentale
c'est la prise en compte de la
pénibilité pour de vrai il te programmes
normalement là nous avions fait pas nous
avions à l'époque du débat proposé un
régime universel de pénibilité j'avais
été un des promoteurs de cette
proposition en considérant qu' à chaque
fois qu'on avait passé une année dans un
poste pénible on devait pouvoir gagner
un mois de départ en retraite 1,2 tout
ça et à évaluer mais pour moi cela
pourrait porte d'entrée c'est d'évaluer
la pénibilité pas l'âge de départ et
l'âge de départ sera calé sur la
pénibilité de chacun ce qui est sûr
c'est que nous devrons travailler
davantage mais je ne demanderai pas
demain à quelqu'un qui pendant 40 ans
aura travaillé dans des conditions est
incroyablement difficile de travailler
plus longtemps qu on a vu des gens qui
puissent travailler jusqu'à 65 ans bien
sûr ils le veulent et s'ils le peuvent
bien sûr et certain je le redis auront
des conditions de travail qui feront
qu'à 63 voulait pas toucher on voulait
pas retarder le départ ce qu'on appelle
l'âge légal alors ce que je souhaite
c'est que nous inversions notre
réflexion et je pense qu'on prend le
sujet à l'envers lorsqu'on se pose la
question de l'âge on prend le sujet
l'envers la vraie question c'est la
porte d'entrée c'est la pénibilité et
donc je souhaite que dans le débat qui
vient nous posions la question de la
pénibilité de chaque métier et en
fonction en région on verra si le
financement est pas insensible
financement l'augmentation des minimes
vieillesse le financement de la
dépendance et tout ça c'est
nécessaire avec eux sur la question la
question du financement est fondamentale
mais enfin aujourd'hui pour vous il ya
un problème de financement des retraites
ou pas parce que par exemple pour jean
luc marchand n'y a pas de problème de
financement navia aujourd'hui un
problème à long terme de financement des
retraites ya surtout un problème de
justice et de lisibilité du système de
retraites est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
croyez ça ne coûte pas plus cher à la
collectivité à la société d'avoir
quelqu'un qui a à 60 ans parce qu'il ne
pourra plus travailler parce qu'il est
physiquement cassé bénéficier d'autres
minima sociaux d'autres systèmes de
prise en charge pour aller jusqu'à sa
retraite ça coûte de toute façon à la
collectivité et je préférais donc que ce
soit le régime de retraite qui soit plus
juste réforme oui mais réforme juste
alors la charge de la dette va
s'alourdir dans les prochains mois est
ce que vous vous continuez chez les
républicains a plaidé pour l'orthodoxie
budgétaire
je ne sais pas ce que c'est que
l'orthodoxie ou en dix ans dix ont
respecté les 3% de déficit public et des
critères de maastricht le sujet c'est
plus un sujet comptable aujourd'hui le
sujet c'est comment est ce qu'on est
capable de faire le ménage dans des
financements des dépenses qui sont
inutiles dans des agences de l'état
notamment de pardon mais on en parle
depuis dix ans les agences vendent de
santé pour lesquels j'ai le plus grand
respect enfin il va falloir arrêter avec
tout ça comment est ce qu'on fait ce
ménage là mais comment est-ce qu'on
investit là où c'est nécessaire comment
on investit dans nos écoles comment on
investit dans nos hôpitaux dans les
salaires de nos soignants parce que
c'est une sujet prioritaire ce avec quoi
il faut en finir c'est la règle
comptable des trois cent mille postes de
fonctionnaires supprimés par les 150000
rien de vous défendiez à la
présidentielle ça ne veut rien dire moi
je ne sais c'est que je ne sais pas ce
que c'est que fonctionnaires en général
il ya des fonctionnaires dont je connais
précisément la mission est ce qu'il faut
c'est regarder les points les uns après
les autres mais sur la dette nous
devrons avoir un débat politique la
dette est un objet politique ce n'est
pas un objet financier au comptable
c'est un objet politique que
faisons-nous de la dette qu'ovide est ce
qu'elle devienne une dette perpétuelle
où passe une proposition de françois
baroin avait à l'époque et que je
soutiens et sur nos dettes
d'investissement comment nous les gérons
à un niveau peut être plus européen dans
les années qui viennent c'est un vrai
débat politique que nous n'avons pas eu
jusque là qu'il fallait renégocier les
traités à bruxelles sur cette question
il faut devenir militaire naturellement
les renégocier puisqu'ils ne sont plus
appliquées déjà depuis bien longtemps
donc il faut les changer il faut
clarifier cette règle est mieux de
changer la règle plutôt que de l
ensemble en double à parme dit désobéir
c'est aujourd'hui la fin du port du
masque dans les transports est-ce que
vous demander l'abrogation de la loi sur
le pass vaccinale ou est ce que pour
vous il faut conserver quand même cette
loi au cas où on aurait besoin de
réactiver ce pas de l'accident je ne
souhaite pas que nous conservions les
régimes d'exception donc je ne serai pas
que nous habitions au régime d'exception
le pass sanitaire le pass vaccinale
relève d'un régime d'exception de notre
démocratie tout ce qui relève du régime
d'exception ne doit pas devenir une
habitude et donc dès que nous pouvons le
retirer de notre corps législatif il
faut le faire quitte à y revenir ensuite
mais pour moi c'est aujourd'hui une
priorité ce que je crains le plus c'est
la coutume en ce que nous aurions les
uns les autres progressivement à des
règles d'exception démocratique on ne
doit jamais siècle s'il a connu tant que
c'est aujourd'hui le moment de la
brasserie mais je plaide cela depuis le
départ en disant ne profitons pas du
confort des régimes d'exception parce
qu'ils sont confortables pour le pouvoir
politique mais ils sont nés face à la
démocratie on est au mans pourrait être
en grande pénurie de médecins cet été
comment est ce que vous vous l'expliquer
malgré toutes les mesures qui ont été
prises notamment le ségur de la santé
beaucoup de mesures qui ont été prises
en faveur des métiers médicaux après le
covin pas seulement les médecins aussi
des infirmiers dans mon département
l'hôpital principal est aujourd'hui en
plan blanc nous avons fermé des dizaines
de lits parce que nous n'avons plus de
soignants les infirmiers qui
démissionnent des infirmières qui
démissionnent de leur métier et le ségur
n'a rien réglé j'ose le dire rien réglé
d'abord parce qu'il a créé des
injustices et ensuite parce que le fond
du sujet c'est pas le salaire le fond du
sujet sur les conditions de travail et
donc il nous faut en urgence réinvestir
dans nos structures hospitalières dans
la médecine de ville pour que nos
soignants sont plus nombreux ça commence
par là tant qu'on n'aura pas réglé ça on
n'aura rien réglé la proposition que
nous avons porté durant les élections
présidentielles que je reprends à mon
compte durant les élections législatives
de lutter contre les déserts médicaux en
permettant d'envoyer quatre mille jeunes
médecins en mission sur leur dernière
année de formation dans les territoires
ça relève aussi de cette capacité à
soigner à nouveau nos concitoyens mére
investissions dans l'hôpital en urgence
absolue c'est une urgence vitale
aujourd'hui s'il faut aller plus loin et
est ce qu'il faut faire des réquisitions
de médecins notamment face à cette
situation qu'on anticipe pour l'été mais
vous réquisitionné qui le problème c'est
la pénurie aujourd'hui c'est sur les
bâtisses à leur demande et décalé leur
va devancer à partir en vacances ça ce
sont des pansements sur une jambe de
bois oui
c'est ce qui se passe déjà dans les
plans blancs lorsque les plans blancs
sont déclenchés vous avez déjà des
réquisitions tout ça n'est rien de
nouveau vous avez déjà des soignants
pendant de vous le dire qui depuis deux
ans décalent leurs vacances vous allez
comme moi dans les hôpitaux ça fait déjà
deux ans que ça fait deux ans que le
gouvernement gère mal la crise ça fait
deux ans qu'on gère la pénurie pardon ça
fait 15 ans qu'on gère la pénurie et sur
ces sujets qui sont des sujets
fondamentaux il va falloir passer à une
vraie révolution la droite était au
pouvoir l'a pas le
je vous ai parlé de 15 euros sage
englobe à peu près tout le monde la
gauche l'a juste monde a sauté
définitivement c'est une règle comptable
d'ailleurs appliqué par des petits
comptables qui n'a absolument aucun sens
pendant ce quinquennat vous avez voté un
certain nombre de textes 1 avec la
majorité par exemple vous avez voté la
réforme de la sncf il ordonnance travail
certain nombre de lois d'urgence sur le
co vide quel est ce que vous allez
continuer sur cette lignée pour ce
prochain quinquennat si votre question
est de savoir si les types d'oppositions
allez-vous pratiquer un jeu lorsque les
choses vont dans le bon sens sont les
votes évidemment mais je peux vous faire
la liste aussi tous les textes ceux
contre lesquels je me suis élevé face au
gouvernement on ne gère pas une
opposition on n'est pas un bon opposant
parce qu'on est bête et méchant moi
j'étais très ferme avec le gouvernement
je continuerai à l'être il porte une
politique que je ne partage pas et dont
je continuerai à le faire et quand les
textes vont dans le bon sens il faudrait
être absolument bête et méchant stupide
pour ne pas aller voter ou alors il
faudrait s'appelait la france insoumise
ce qu'ils ont fait depuis cinq ans mais
constructive ou pas j'en sais rien tout
ce que je sais c'est que quand ça sert
mon pays je le soutiens mais il ya bien
des situations où j'ai été en
affrontement avec le gouvernement
je prenais l'exemple de la france est
soumise depuis cinq ans ça a été une
volonté systématique de bloquer
l'assemblée moi c'est pas ma volonté et
ça ne m'empêche pas d'être extrêmement
ferme à l'égard d' emmanuel macron et de
ces politiques ont parlé de position
constructive est ce que vous êtes seriez
favorable à ce que l air participe à une
commission transpartisane pour étudier
les voies et moyens dans les formes
institutionnelles emmanuel macron moi je
connais une commission transpartisane
qui très intéressante qui s'appelle
l'assemblée nationale et j'en ai plein
les bottes de ces commissions de ces
bidules et de ces machins qui consiste à
contourner la représentation nationale
c'est-à-dire l'assemblée nationale si un
débat doit avoir lieu c'est à
l'assemblée nationale est pas autour
d'une table entre gens bien choisi pour
tenter de court circuiter le
fonctionnement normal de notre
démocratie dans vous non parce qu'il
s'agit de faire des travaux
préparatoires sur une réforme qui est
peu consensuel on l'a bien vu pendant le
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron mais aussi
de ses prédécesseurs l'idée de défricher
le terrain faire des propositions qui
puisse effectivement être acceptée par
tous et enfin et ensuite débattu au
parlement vous dites c'est une perte de
temps on amuse la galerie on a eu
quelques expériences qui jusque là ont
plutôt consisté à amuser la galerie et
je dis tout ça peut se faire au sein de
l'assemblée nationale on a des
commissions spéciales on a tout à fait
les outils pour défricher comme vous le
dites parfaitement avant que ça n'arrive
en séance publique mais je le redis
c'est la représentation nationale qui
doit reprendre la main sur le
fonctionnement de la démocratie
merci beaucoup brive est à toutes ces
questions un maintien sur le processus
de choix du premier ministre dont on
parle aujourd'hui
personne ne veut le job a tweeté jean
luc mélenchon avait main avant même de
savoir quel était le choix ultime
d'ailleurs d'emmanuel le maquereau est
un cdd de missions d'intérim il revient
sur son idée qui sera lui le premier
ministre personne ne veut le job est ce
que c'est quelque chose qui vous a
traversé l'esprit ou est ce que vous
diriez comme ségolène royal dans le fond
ça ne se refuse pas matignon je ss que
personne n'en veut je n'imagine pas je
vois que ça se bouscule crème un petit
peu au portillon mais peut-être que ça
pose une question plus fondamentale de
ce qu'est aujourd'hui l'engagement
politique est d'ailleurs dans les
profils qui vont qui circulent dans les
noms qui vont être peut-être annoncé
on voit bien que sont plus des profils
de serviteurs il n'y a rien de péjoratif
de notre serviteur que des profils de
responsables politiques qui viendrait
avec avec leur combat avec leur ouïe
leur personnalité leur âme politique
peut-être que c'est l'air du temps moi
ça ne me plaît pas beaucoup de voir au
fond
la vie politique devenir un grand champ
de hauts fonctionnaires
pourquoi lorsque nos fonctionnaires et
servent l'état jean castex est
insuffisante est comme un grand au
fonctionnaire avec un sens de l'intérêt
général chevillée au corps mais je n'ai
pas de l'admirer passe à 1 je les admire
mais je considère que c'est une mission
complémentaire de la mission politique
la mission du responsable politique
n'est pas de se confondre avec les hauts
fonctionnaires et quand je dis ça c'est
parce que je respecte profondément les
hauts fonctionnaires le rôle du
responsable politique c'est de mener des
combats auxquels il croit profondément
de ne jamais les abandonner quitte à
parfois bousculé les
éléments établis par les hauts
fonctionnaires ce que je sais ce que je
ne fais raquette et un haut
fonctionnaire qui a accompagné après les
préoccupations des français jacques
chirac y était et est tout sauf un haut
fonctionnaire dans son comportement et
dans une attitude ce que j'essaie
simplement de dire c'est que pour moi la
confusion des genres est un problème que
ça peut paraître rassurant mais pour moi
c'est inquiétant sophie de ravinel est
face à vous de la rédaction du figaro a
des tas de questions à vous poser oui et
justement bonjour ayant brillé sur c'est
ce que vous dites de cet engagement
politique on voit bien que vous même
vous avez un profil très politique
évidemment vous avez parlé de votre
engagement tout à l'heure nous nous
entendu à 16 ans de droiture politique
de vertu on sent chez vous l' envie de
servir vous parliez des serviteurs dans
un sens positif aussi pas seulement
voilà est-ce que vous vous sentiriez de
servir de servir votre parti jusqu'à
prendre prétendre
à prendre la tête des républicains au
congrès à l'automne prochain je crois à
deux choses d'abord aux étapes je suis
député pendant encore quelques semaines
je ne suis pas certaine de le redevenir
sont les électeurs qui vont choisir et
dont même manière de les respecter
aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas leur dire
vous êtes un marche pied pour autre
chose moi ce que je souhaite plus que
tout c'est redevenir député de ma
circonscription et puis ensuite on verra
mais je dois vous dire un autre mot de
la suite moi je crois à la conquête
politique je crois que quand on y croit
soi même on peut embarquer avec soi
beaucoup de monde c'est ça la politique
c'est pas une affaire de billard a dit
band c'est une affaire de conquête et
donc peut-être que mon profil paraît
curieux étonnant c'est vrai en classique
oui peut-être
d'une autre époque politique peut-être
quand je n'en sais rien mais peut-être
même que sur le papier si jamais la
question c'est d'autres périodes
politiques d'ailleurs pas été parfaite
toujours mais je sais que j'ai admiré
plus jeune des grands personnages
politiques à côté desquels je suis un
tout petit dès philippe séguin des des
malraux voyez que la filiation je ne me
compare pas seul instant à tout cela
mais je dis simplement que ce sont eux
les chirac des pompidou qui m'ont donné
envie de faire de la politique parce que
je trouvais que c'était beau il y avait
mis le défaut évidemment ce sont pas des
saints et tout ce que je dis mais il y
avait quelque chose de beau mais je ne
comprenais ce qu'il disait et ce qu'il
voulait faire et donc si tout ça peut
être utile à ma famille politique je
serais sûrement pas le seul à vouloir
mener ses batailles est-ce que vous
quand même avoir tout ce qu'ils font
éventuellement vous élire ou voter pour
vous la roue législatives peuvent
l'entendre ça c'est pas déshonorant
d'avoir une ambition forte parce que
tout ce dont vous parlez avait cette
ambition il exprimé publiquement y
compris sans doute avant les échéances
vida est ce que vous ne pouvez pas
devant ceux qui vont vous élire assumer
cette ambition que vous auriez de servir
votre parti en plus de les servir eu
localement savez ça fait cinq ans que je
suis député et 6 lits à 13 ans vous
m'auriez dit qu'un jour je serai député
de mon pays je ne l'aurais pas cru une
seule seconde et donc je mesure chaque
jour la chance de la confiance immense
que l'on me fait il manque depuis mon
plus jeune âge dans l'oeil mais là vous
tourner autour du hip hop non je tourne
pas autour du pot je le dis ça parce que
jamais je n'ai griller les étapes jamais
et je ne souhaite pas le faire ni
aujourd'hui ni dans les semaines qui
viennent la seule chose que je peux vous
dire c'est que je me sens aujourd'hui un
peu plus solide pour mener des batailles
auxquelles je n'aurais jamais pensé par
le passé oui alors justement si ça n'est
pas celle de la direction du parti ce
que ça pourrait être au sein du groupe
parlementaire pour en prendre la tête
non probablement pas et je le sais pas
de quoi aller parce que je ne sais pas
de connaître le goût pour cette ce
leadership là ce que j'ai appris alors
que vous venez de le répéter tout à
l'heure que le parlement était un
exercice les débats les plus
fondamentaux d'investir vous êtes une
belle mission surtout dans le cadre
d'une réforme constitutionnelle avec
éventuellement les évolutions du régime
fait raison je vous redis qu'on verrons
comment les choses arrivent ce que j'ai
appris depuis deux ans c'est le goût du
parti politique et se glisse grâce à
cela que le goût du parti politique
c'est notamment grâce à christian jacob
parce que je n'ai pas été fabriqués dans
un parti politique je suis un garçon
assez solitaire mme parcours est plutôt
solitaire personnel et politique et donc
quand christian jacob confie la mission
de secrétaire général les républicains
je me dis d'abord que je n'y arriverai
jamais parce que pour moi le collectif
s'est pas c'est pas un instinct premier
et j'ai beaucoup appris de ce que le
collectif amène à la bataille politique
c'est un apprentissage et donc c'est
vrai que mener des aventures collectives
n'était pas mon tempérament il ya
quelques temps vous avez appris et que
désormais je les a pris et j'y prends
goût autant aux bras au point de diriger
un groupe à l'assemblée je vous redis on
en reparlera le moment venu mais vous
avez tellement dit il n'y a pas brillé
que c'était le moment venu de la
nouvelle génération en fruits dès votre
mantra vous l'avez vous en fera voir les
mesures malaisie sophie noyer mais
justement parce que moi ce que je me
posais comme question cette nouvelle
génération vous avez parlé de nicolas
sarkozy tout à l'heure vous avez dit que
vous aviez tourné la page qu'il fallait
tout faux vieux vielles même rendu
service en assumant cette rupture pour
une nouvelle génération est ce que
justement il n'a pas quand même était à
l'origine nicolas sarkozy aussi est ce
qu'il faut faire le bilan est-ce que
c'est pas aux jeunes de faire le bilan
de l'action qu'il a menée et d'aller
jusqu'à dire qu'il est lui même à
l'origine d'une rupture dans votre parti
dans une ligne identitaire et dans une
ligne plus sociale la vôtre c'est quand
même mieux avec patrick buisson qui a
provoqué l'apparition alors enfin de
ceux qui aujourd'hui incarne cette ligne
identitaire est ce que ça ne peut pas le
dire plus clairement d'ailleurs je le
dis je lui dis que notre échec électoral
il vient depuis la ligne buisson avec
tous les épisodes que nous avons connue
en nicolas sarkozy a été responsable et
je les dis très clairement enfin tout
cas le choix de la deuxième campagne
électorale et les français on tranche
est est ce que la nouvelle génération
est utile oui elle est ma volonté c'est
pas de faire une guerre quel est votre
génération elle peut pas clarifié les
choix aussi et c'est pour ça qu'elle est
utile je pense le nouvelle génération à
l'étude d'abord pour parler des français
auquel nous ne parlons plus et c'est
utile y compris à d'autres générations
dans ma famille politique qui sentent
bien que au moment où le rn jeunes
leaders moment on les a soumis à des
jeunes leaders mans et même écran a fait
monter une nouvelle génération il faut
aussi que la droite républicaine le
fasse et puis l'avantagé d'une nouvelle
génération c'est qu'elle peut plus
facilement tourner des pages qui sont
difficiles à tourner pour pour d'autres
humains y compris jusqu'à assumer une
rupture regarder julien aubert propose
deux des jus des parties jumeaux des
parties de faire deux parties est ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous
soutiendriez vous non je n'en je
souhaite c'est que les républicains
solution soit à rebâtir ceux qui veulent
partir partiront ce qui est certain
c'est que ce que je veux pas y avoir
deux partis frères bon je ne sais pas
frères je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
mais la vue l'ouie opposés ou dans ces
cas là on en fait qu'un seul nom mais
tout ça ce sont des tactiques monde
éliminés sur l'essence il ya ben non je
suis passé sont inconciliables ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'on prend pas faire du
consensus c'est qu'après les
législatives arrivent à l'intraitable
clarté d'une nouvelle génération faudra
créer mais il faudra clarifier vous
savez j chirac l'a fait sur la fracture
sociale à l'époque et je pense sûrement
que dans de nouvelles de notre
génération nous avons cette
responsabilité mais c'est vraiment pas
une guerre de génération c est ce qu
aujourd'hui la jeune génération chez les
républicains n'est pas une chance pour
tout le monde je sais que c'est pas
hyper facile elle a gardé des choses
différentes sections en général je pense
que c'est ce que nous avons à faire et
pour répondre tellement aux questions du
coup je le ferai avec d'autres je
prendrai mes responsabilités avec
d'autres je mènerai les aventures que
nous voulons mener j'espère que ce sera
au sein du parti et je crois que c'est
possible en le refondant totalement
jusqu'à son ombre ble ment mais tout ça
ce sont des étapes qui viennent après
safia sa fille sur le congrès dire que
vous parliez tout à l'heure des
tentations d'arrière boutique qui devait
être sanctionné on sent votre fermeté et
c'est pour ça que je vous posais la
question de savoir si vous vouliez
prendre ce leadership parce qu'on sent
on sent chez vous cette envie de de
brusques et ça c'est que cette ablation
d'arrière boutique par exemple pour un
exemple concret imaginons à l'assemblée
ceux qui vont voter celle et l air par
exemple la confiance au gouvernement est
ce que vous seriez favorable pour les
exclure du parti pour cela ils doivent
s'exclure de même et s'ils le font pas
il faut il faut les sortir toutes les
statues les sortes il faut changer les
normalement on aurait pas se poser ces
questions c'est la vertu qui devrait lui
il faudrait peut-être comme elle mais on
va le rétablir et s'il faut aider les
récents appliquer la vertu on prendra
des décisions nécessaires défense et
déshonorant vote de confiance des femmes
et des hommes qui n'auraient rien à
faire ensemble n'ont pas à se forcer à
vivre ensemble politiquement et c'est
pas un drame paname il faut que nous
ayons demain une formation politique qui
soit cohérente et je le redis si
certains veulent tenter les aventures
sur leurs côtés très à droite ou sur
leurs côtés très lrm qu'il le fasse tant
qu'il restera quelques combattants pour
remonter la boutique ce sera suffisant
pour le faire c'est quand chirac a lancé
son aventure ils n'étaient pas nombreux
ils n'étaient pas nombreux et je compare
pas les périodes mais je dis simplement
que si nous retrouvons du sens dans le
message que nous voulons porter qui doit
être un message populaire et pas
identitaire alors nous aurons un chemin
et ceux qui veulent porter cette
aventure le ferons ce qu'ils ne veulent
pas porteront leur propre aventure
est-ce que vous allez la porter avec
xavier bertrand xavier fait partie de
ceux qui veulent porter cette aventure
mais gérard larcher aussi christian
jacob aussi il y en a beaucoup d'autres
et vous savez mon travail depuis six
mois il est de parler avec tout le monde
ce que je ne faisais pas nécessairement
toujours de parler y compris avec mes
aînés avec qui nous avons eu parfois des
tensions d'aller convaincre que ce que
je défends n'est pas une lubie que le
message une droite populaire c'est
électoralement payant mais surtout c'est
le coeur de la politique de pouvoir
changer la vie de nos concitoyens la
méta politique tout ça c'est de la
littérature
revenons à ce qui fait le coeur de la
politique s'occuper des problèmes des
français qui ne sont pas des petits
problèmes c'est à partir de ça qu'on
fait une idéologie politique c'est pas
l'un vers un
mood valérie pécresse vous en avez assez
peu parlé spontanément elle a été votre
maman est-ce que vous avez des contacts
avec elle récemment pas dernièrement
juste après les présidentielles oui est
ce que vous êtes au courant d'abord de
sa grande préoccupation enfin de nous en
est sa grande préoccupation c'est à dire
pouvoir honorer sa dette est-ce qu'elle
a réuni 2 millions qui lui manque je ne
sais pas où elle en est aujourd'hui pour
une femme un être préoccupé direct
ouailles avaient d'année oui été
plusieurs à le faire
et je pense que notre famille politique
aidera pour ce qui est nécessaire et
parce que ça a été notre candidate et là
aussi c'est une sorte de code d'honneur
on a band pas en abandonne pas nos
candidats en rase campagne ni mal ni
matériellement ni politiquement moi je
suis admiratif de sa solidité il ya
plein de choses qu'on peut discuter dans
sa campagne mais cette solidité pour moi
fait un immense respect que j'ai à son
égard je la connaissais en réalité assez
peu
au moins pu l'observer qu'elle a été
l'erreur majeure de la campagne est ce
que vous avez fait cette analyse qui
permet normalement de repartir sur des
bases et vous prétendez pouvoir le faire
nous aurons à le faire dans les mois qui
viennent mais seulement que la
principale erreur est de n'avoir pas
rompu avec tous ceux qui nous tenait
depuis des années que la sarkozie on
fait partie des stratégies en font
partie aussi moi ça m'effraie de voir
que par exemple la droite républicaine
ne parle plus du tout à la jeunesse un
parti politique qui ne parlent plus la
jeunesse c'est un parti politique qui ne
parlent pas aux français et probablement
que nous avons au fond géré cette
campagne présidentielle avec des parts
de marché électoral en oubliant que
notre dernière part de marché lectorale
qui était celle de françois fillon avait
fondu comme neige au soleil ce qu'il
faut désormais c'est aller à la conquête
d'un électorat qu'on a perdu et pour ça
il faut prendre des risques est ce qu'on
en a beaucoup pris durant cette campagne
électorale et pour prendre un risque
risque de positionnement politique
lorsque je prône le fait de reparler aux
catégories les plus populaires c'est un
vrai risque politique mais quand les
retraites aussi avec la question des
salaires avec la question des retraites
et de ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
sur la pénibilité avec la question
d'écologie que disons-nous sur
l'écologie aujourd'hui le monde sa a
péché dans la canche sans doute
peut-être de valérie pécresse ce point
de l'écologie oui c'est que les jeunes
n'ont pas été sur ce point là comme
d'autres comme d'autres sujets moi je
crois vraiment que la stratégie
politique désormais elle doit consister
à identifier
les problèmes quotidienne nos
concitoyens et leur lit par sorte de
snobisme intellectuel on a considéré que
la politique ça méritait pas de
s'occuper des problèmes de sous
préfecture mais moi je pense que c'est
là qu'on construit une sensibilité
politique une idéologie politique et
c'est ce chemin là qu'il faut faire on
ne fera pas en trois semaines on ne fera
pas en un mois on a des mois de chantier
devant nous et ça commence après les
législatives vous parliez tout à l'heure
de valérie pécresse qui avait pas su
s'émanciper de nicolas sarkozy quand
même pour revenir à nicolas sarkozy
escape a une responsabilité de sa part
ou si vous l'avez dit mais ce qu'il faut
pas quand même insisté dessus sur le
fait de savoir ce qu'il a ce qu'il a pu
faire pour l'empêcher dans sa campagne -
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est elle
qui aurait dû nettement prendre son
risque le pouvait-elle lorsque vous avez
été ce que vous auriez fait à sa place
c'est trop facile d'imaginer ce que
j'aurais fait à sa place non dites nous
ce que vous auriez fait à sa place ce
qui est sûr c'est que moi je n'ai pas
été un ministre de nicolas sarkozy et
que je n'ai pas de nombreuses années
de même la hiérarchie politique et donc
nécessairement la relation je peux avoir
avec lui n'est pas la même c'est une
question de génération oui c'est une
question de moment et je comprends que
lorsqu'on a été ministre de nicolas
sarkozy on n'est pas on n'est pas la
force nécessaire pour claquer la porte
et puis et puis si on avait plein le
rapport affectif
avec ce qu'il en réservons éthique
absolument sûrement parce que je n'ai
pas servi mais mais moi j'ai des
épisodes de ma vie personnelle dans
lesquelles nicolas sarkozy a eu des
attentions extrêmement forte
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour lui à quel
moment par sont des moments personnels
n'est pas dévoilé donc je connais sa
grande humanité et d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que je lui ai dit que je ne lui
trouvez rien de commun avec emmanuel
macron pour moi c'est une
incompréhension les données vous
l'expliquez comment les deux personnages
sont à mille lieues l'un de l'autre
quand sarkozy est une boule d'affection
je considère que manuel macron est une
effet de politiquement de cire et donc
je ne comprends pas qu'il appartient à
la confrérie résident oui elle n'est pas
très importante
il fait un point commun important est
peut-être aussi que pas peut-être dans
notre nature humaine ce qui est toujours
difficile c'est de tourner les pages de
ne plus exister dans le moment est donc
emmanuel macron et de ce point de vue
une bouée qui permet de continuer à
exister je le comprend peut-être qu'à sa
place je fonctionnerai exactement de la
même manière pour exister en fait qu'il
entretient ce lien étroit exister
politiquement
il ya là qu'il va être issue pour lui
selon le type man vous savez de nicolas
sarkozy pour moi je suis pas sûr que ce
que je dise va lui plaire mais ce n'est
pas très grave pour moi est quelqu'un d'
humainement très simple quand j très
simple autres errements emmanuel macron
quand j'ai très simple et respectueux et
chacune et chacun d'entre nous est ce
qu'on n'a pas envie de continuer à
exister bien sûr que oui et donc ça vaut
pour nicolas sarkozy comme pour chacune
et chacun et j'en arrive à une question
qui nous sort un peu de nos
problématiques habituel mais puisque
vous l'évoquez vous la politique c'est
pour toute la vie
c'est ma vie j'ai été fabriqués avec sa
wii à l'ancienne alors oui forme
athlètes sont qu'un par ma classe et
attend classique que ça parce que mes
parents ne faisait pas de politique
parce que j'ai pas fais des twin parce
qu'elles sont là les tangos conditions
invraisemblables donc j'ai pas le profil
typique de la politique mais c'est ce
qui me fait vibrer quotidiennement et
c'est ce qui donne du sens à ma vie ici
je fais pas ça je rachèterai une école
de surf gérer faire du sort elle est
toute dernière question il fallait bien
qu'elle arrive quand même elisabeth
bornes premier ministre quelle est votre
première réaction bon c'est pas une
grande surprise ça va être du castex bis
parlé tout à l'heure de hauts
fonctionnaires oui des serviteurs l1 est
pour moi l'illustration même demandé
moins ce que pense profondément
elisabeth bornes quelles sont ces
convictions politiques profondes je n'en
sais rien peut-être qu'on le dit donc
c'est une bonne nouvelle ou une mauvaise
nouvelle pour la france c'est banal
c'est banal oui je trouve ça banal je
lui souhaite bonne chance dans la
mission qui sera la sienne mais je
considère que c'est banal c'est pas un
profil qui vous semble propre à emmener
le nouveau mandat je nouvelles méthodes
non pas tout à fait je trouve que c'est
tout à fait dans leur cas les réseaux
justement c'est banal parce que jean
castex et est de ce point de vue dans sa
méthode politique banal je parle pas du
tout des personnes distinctes combien
les choses qu'on n'est pas bien lisabeth
bornes mais je dis simplement que ça ne
vient pas amener
une connotation politique un combat
particulier qu'elle embarquera avec elle
moi je lui ai suivi l assemblée
nationale dans ses différents postes de
ministre je les trouvais
propre sur elle ce qui est déjà une
qualité
ça veut dire quoi ce sans aucune
d'inspirer disent oui sans elle vous
tailler des hauts fonctionnaires tout à
l'heure c'est l'heure gazier s'est pas
c'est pas terrible les hauts
fonctionnaires il y évoquait moore la
non elle incarne je veux corriger ça
s'est fini aux fonctionnaires pour vous
dans l'est la
menace qu'il ya de plus nécessaire
lorsqu'on est aux fonctionnaires la
seule question c'est est-ce que un
premier ministre et un haut
fonctionnaire dernière question pourquoi
à votre avis manuel macron l'at elle
nomme la chienne nommée sûrement parce
que il considère que celles et ceux qui
sont autour de lui ne doivent pas avoir
d'aspérités politique c'est confortable
d'avoir autour de soi des serviteurs
c'est beaucoup plus confortable que
d'avoir à gérer des personnalités
politiques sauf que je crois que ce qui
vous donne de la force et d'avoir autour
de vous des personnalités politiques qui
vous perturbe un peu qu'ils sont
capables de vous embarquer là où vous
n'étiez pas aller elisabeth bande
n'embarquera personnes là où emmanuel
macron dedans c'est un mauvais signal
c'est un signal qui ressemble à la macro
ni parfaitement en tout cas je ne vois
pas où est le signal de la nouveauté du
changement de méthode mais une fois plus
je souhaite bonne chance à les avait
deux bornes parce que je souhaite bonne
chance à mon pays merci beaucoup à
aurélien pradié d'avoir été ce soir dans
notre émission merci sophy
du figaro et on retrouve bien sûr la
semaine prochaine à 19h30 sur lcp et
public sénat bonne semaine
[Musique]